we're gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to find
out who we really are like which
American Idol person we really are we
really maybe I am just putting this all
on for show and truly I'm Lionel Richie
underneath this no you are truly going
to be Katy Perry you're right how about
that Luke wants to be me he wants to be
like next season's Versace she was a
modern American pastime to fill up your
Sunday afternoon TV and chill watching
football all day brunch in scrolling
through Instagram online shopping or
playing video games
mine is brunches I knew it no way I'm
going online shopping very predictable
watching football
LabCorp all day pick a music idol whose
discography you could never give up
Whitney Houston
Dolly Parton cher Madonna Stevie Nicks
or Janet Jackson Wow
I want to play all their songs but
honestly I've always looked up to
Madonna you might predict that I would
pick dolly although I love dolly but I
gotta go with Miss Jackson if you're
nasty Wow god this is so difficult
because I am half of them are gonna call
you Amy all of them are gonna call me
come on Lionel okay well okay Whitney
Whitney and yeah I mean I'm in love with
the girl can I pick dolly as my second
fix might choose a Katy Perry song that
best fits your personality waking up in
Vegas
last Friday night hot and cold roar
swish swish firework
I am definitely waking up in Vegas yeah
you are like that roar
[Music]
well my personality that for this show
it would be it would have to be swish
swish swish okay pick a snack to get you
through a long day of work popcorn
chocolate almonds pretzels chips
and forget the snacks give me another
cup of coffee popcorn what you eat I
love popcorn will heat it to death I'm
eating chips model I didn't know we
should've put a little caramel on it
what about what about spike seasoning I
love a truffle oil and that's a real dry
rub on your popcorn that's outrageous I
don't know what does that can you live
through that lastly choose a song to
sing at karaoke night let's get it on by
Marvin Gaye dancing queen by ABBA
don't stop believing by journey friends
and low places by Garth Brooks how will
I know by Whitney Houston or achy-breaky
heart by Billy Ray Cyrus no Marvin a gay
I'm between two oh yeah
I'll probably do dancing queen I am
don't stop believin because of your
hilarious and exuberant personality
you're Lana Richie you're early in a bad
mood and you know just what to get
myself hey Lionel that's wonderful man
well I picked myself because I'm trying
to be as authentic as possible even to a
fault I am honest playful and sometimes
a bit flirty you're the irresistible
Katy Perry thank you do you have an
infectious personality that lights up
any room not to mention you have a heart
of gold
that's really nice whoever wrote that
can they write my bio or something
nobody click don't mind so I don't get
to see what your Luke Bryan do you make
lots of noises with your nose you fart
under the judge that's so sorry you
sometimes have green part and you've got
a beer belly
[Laughter]
[Music]